solidarity unity respect
rare applause from mps as the house of
commons roses won to the ukrainian
ambassador
he and the country heard the strongest
condemnation yet from boris johnson what
we have seen already uh from vladimir
putin's regime in the use of the
munitions that they have already been uh
they've been dropping on on innocent
civilians mr speaker in my view already
fully qualifies as as a war crime but
it's actions not words demanded by the
labour leader what about the owner of
chelsea football club roman abramovich
he's a person of interest to the home
office because of his links to the
russian state and his public association
with corrupt activity and practices
last week the prime minister said that
abramovic is facing sanctions he later
corrected the record to say that he
isn't well
why not isn't he
there's more to come says boris johnson
what we will uh publish in addition uh
mr speaker is a full list of all those
associated uh with the putin regime the
vice is tightening on the putin regime
and it will continue to tighten
calls came from all sides to do more
even using the legal protections of
parliament to list possible targets i
don't want more nobody wants war
but we're not even
sanctioning sergey shoigu
the russian defense minister yet
nor igor ossipoff
the commander of the black sea fleet
aurasmanov
or the members of the russian duma who
voted for this war
at prime minister's questions kierstarma
said that two flats in here worth 11
million pounds and just a few hundred
yards from downing street are owned by
an ally of vladimir putin
igor chavalov is on the eu sanctions
list but not on the british one
kierstarmer asked why
now officials say that cases involving
russian oligarchs are tricky they take
time they don't want to end up making
mistakes and in court but pressure is
building on all sides to fill the gaps
in the sanctions regime
tonight the oligarch sell-off begins
roman abramovich announced he is selling
chelsea football club thought to be
asking four billion pounds for it and
promising the proceeds will go to the
victims of the ukraine conflict more
sanctions are coming more sell-offs
likely unpicking a three-decade
relationship with modern russia
in haste sam coates sky news westminster